congress passed its most significant gun
reform bill in decades sends it to biden
cnbc story scrambling to respond to a
recent
uh spate a
spat of bloody gun massacres u.s
lawmakers passed the most significant
federal gun restrictions in decades on
friday following years of false starts
and failures to tighten gun laws
following senate passage
late thursday the house passed a
bipartisan bill that takes steps to
restrict gun access to younger buyers
domestic violence offenders and others
who could pose a risk to their
communities the bipartisan safer
communities act
also was would fund the school safety
and mental health programs the house
approved it by 243 to 193 and 193 as 14
republicans joined all democrats the
legislation says to president biden
who's expected to quickly sign it into
law is this progress
i i think that the the passing of these
laws
attacking not the problem but the
popularity of the shock of this thing
you have
securing schools that's a no-brainer we
should have been doing that
for the last 20 years my daughter is a
school teacher
i have done the security survey pro bono
for every school that she ever worked or
led
um and they're buttoned down and you
have police officers
um
it's it's just
we're fighting
a political battle where it should be a
moral battle in my opinion
we have the right to defend ourselves
i believe that investing in mental
health i think that that's a very
important one what does that mean though
so that we're investing in mental health
unpacked we we have we have to
keep is the uh see something say
something concept translate it into this
uh i don't remember where the place was
but the uh the second the last uh
incident
that we had the the um the perpetrator
he went to school for a whole week
wearing a hazmat suit
does i mean is that a normal behavior or
is that
you should you not look into a pattern
of behavior it's a thin line because you
also have what you just said which i
totally agree with
you're innocent until proven guilty
um
so
what do you think roger i'm afraid that
that
as he said earlier i'm not sure any of
those
things are going to change anything
criminals will always find guns
absolutely and it is the cities with the
most restrictive gun policies in the
country where gun violence is is the
greatest in the case of the parkland
shooter
there were no less than seven calls to
this guy's house that never seemed to
get over to the fbi
uh he had been baker acted he'd been
taken involuntarily they gave him
psychotropic drops drugs they put him
back out on the street and he killed
people so i i agree with he said i think
there has to be a greater emphasis on
mental health guns don't kill people
people kill people criminals
miss credence will always get their
hands on guns what does that franchise
always say about uh
gangsters and and uh
yeah exactly what he just said the fact
that they'll they'll get their hands on
guns but but but you know like the left
and the right has
bullet points of three things that
everybody says and everybody keeps
saying it invest into mental health okay
i've heard a billion people say listen
to mental health
you know do this do that the other day
we were talking with michael francis and
we said even if they raise
the uh what do you call it limited 18 to
21 even if they make this even if they
do that even if they do this
ninety percent of the what they call it
uh mass shootings would have been
prevented even if they do that it would
have been prevented because they still
got some of them their guns they got it
illegally or some of them that got it
even the kid who got it he wasn't on any
kind of medication that's anxiety
medication or anything like that so
how much of that is
you know deeper that's going on within
america's values and principles and
morals how much of that is the amount of
drugs that's in the hands of kids with
big pharma advertising the solution
being take this medicine take this
medicine take this medicine
how much of it is the video games how
much of it is us watching on tv
that over and over and over again they
keep turning these guys that are doing
mass shootings into heroes and we keep
talking about them
there has to be something because even
this strategy on what they're going to
be doing
90 something percent of them would have
been prevented
so does anybody really know the solution
or is it just pure political game that
both sides are playing
what do you think
there's no question that um had the
police officers either in texas or in
parkland done their jobs
that those mass shootings could have
been prevented ironically here in
parkland the officer in charge of school
security trained others in crisis
management
but then when the time came he stepped
down he didn't do his job so how do you
so so so think about that so he did the
training
and then when it came down to it still
didn't do it he froze he froze so so
again so then what is the solution
because
if we say we need more training
okay we did and even the training that
was done it still didn't happen
so does anybody really have the solution
that's going to help address this it's a
company it has to be a combination of
things
buttoning down the schools
is something that it's a reality
you cannot in good conscience bring
children and put them into that
environment unless you're able to
protect them
but one thing that we haven't talked
about here is how many people how many
police officers feel empowered
under this administration under this
current culture
where they're being defunded you know
you're they're always guilty until
proving innocent if at all possible
don't get me wrong i've been in harm's
way more than once
so i know what it is to go to a door and
go
but i've gone through the door and that
was their job to do
but again
there's not a hundred percent fixed for
any of this it's five percent here five
percent mental health get buttoned down
the schools better training for the
police but also consequences there's
gotta be consequences these police
officers that did not go in there
should be kicked out of the force
because if you are in an airborne unit
in the military and you decide not to
jump on a combat guess what
you're going to jail so it it that we
need to you know make them accountable
for for that mistake so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
you